As we get ready to graduate from college.
I would appreciate your input on the following question.
I've always loved to take part in a variety of projects and I have ended up in a
leadership position in multiple organizations,
be be it in the student VC from the student body,
my professional fraternity,
et cetera.
In a way,
this is,
this was natural to me.
It's about extreme ownership.
Right.
I love what I was doing.
Shouldn't just slough off that.
That phrase,
an extreme ownership.
Right?
Right.
Yeah.
That's how it should have been said.
Okay.
Is this a okay,
all this stuff.
It's about extreme ownership,
right?
Can't be that hard.
Right.
Kind of kind of thing.
Of course,
the motor strip.
Right.
Okay.
I loved what I was doing.
I had a vision where to take things and I was chosen to lead,
so I felt that I was doing the right thing.
Recently though,
I've started to feel overwhelmed and feel that my productivity has diminished by
being in a managerial position.
It seems harder to see the direct output of my work,
but it's as easy.
It's as easy as always to see what's not working.
I don't want to be let go of any projects because I'll still love to make love
to take ownership of them and he says,
I don't want to be liquid,
says I don't want to let go of any projects because I still love to take
ownership of them.
Oh yes,
yes,
yes.
Okay.
Loves take [inaudible] identifying symptoms.
Yeah.
You liked the word ownership.
That's like a,
like a really,
I definitely liked the word ownership and as you also know,
I also like another word that's dichotomy.
Dichotomy in order to get seen violations here.
All right,
well either either way,
this guy,
he,
he doesn't want to let go of any projects because I still love to take ownership
of them and lead these organizations,
but I think I'm no longer able to handle this much.
How do you balance those things?
Yeah,
so there is a chapter in the dichotomy of leadership called own it all,
but that's not the title of the chapter.
So the title of chapter continues,
it's the title of the chapter is own it all comma,
but empower others.
And it sounds like this individual who's getting after it,
for sure.
Props getting after it leader's position,
multiple organizations going hard,
taking ownership.
Very cool.
But it sounds like he needs to lean more towards decentralized command because
just because you take ownership of things doesn't mean you're supposed to do
everything that you take ownership of.
It doesn't,
it doesn't actually doesn't work.
What this,
what you need individual is you need subordinate leaders inside these multiple
organizations that you're in charge of,
that you trust and you've got to let them run with the broad guidance and the
mission,
the broad guidance of the mission and with your Commander's intent that that's
how you're gonna work.
As,
so for instance,
when I was in charge of training on the west coast,
I was responsible for a lot of stuff for land warfare,
for maritime operations,
dive operations,
air operations,
close quarters,
urban warfare training,
mobility training,
heavy weapons,
defensive tactics,
combat leadership in every other block,
four guys that are getting ready to deploy to Iraq and Afghanistan.
Oh,
and on top of those tactical things,
I'm in charge.
I'm actually also in charge of safety.
And actually also in charge of maintenance and actually also in charge of the
administration of the command.
That's a lot of stuff to be running,
right?
I know that homes is in charge of,
you know,
the VC firm and the student body.
This,
that stuff too.
This is a lot of stuff.
Could I personally manage and conduct all of those things that I was in charge
of?
Not even close,
not even close,
not you.
You talk about feeling overwhelmed.
You wouldn't last 15 minutes if you tried to be the person that made every
decision in all those different divisions that were inside of the training
command.
So I couldn't manage and run them all myself,
but I had great leaders that I trusted that we're going to make things happen.
And I gave them the broad guidance of what we were trying to do,
what they're part of the mission was the parameters that they were allowed to
work within and then go get some,
and it's the same thing.
Task Unit Commander,
Taos tasking.
Your commander got two platoons,
plus you've got a squad of augmentees plus you get seabees and you've got an
intel fuse and sal and you got interrogators and you've got radio communications
crew and you've got the it crew and you've got,
you've got the whole tactical operation center that you're running.
And it's the same thing.
Like I can't run all that.
Nope,
no human can run all that.
So what are you,
do you have subordinate leaders that have the broad guidance?
They understand what the mission is,
they understand the commander's intent,
they go forward and get after it and they,
they know the parameters and sometimes they have issues and when they have
issues,
you step in and you give him a hand or sometimes they get all of our box.
You've got to put them back in the box.
But it's the same thing.
Even though right now I've got echelon front,
I've got the podcast,
I've got the,
the store,
got the supplements,
the apparel,
the online training,
common out,
we got the t,
the real estate,
the gym,
you get the list goes on.
And I can't,
I can't run all those things.
But I caught people bleeding those things and run on those things.
And I could do the same thing.
It's like,
Hey,
here's the guidance,
here's the mission,
here's the commander's intent,
here's the sanity check on something.
Here's the parameters we're trying to move within.
Okay.
And then go,
go and get some.
Yeah.
So if you do well with decentralized command,
you can handle a lot.
Now,
could you possibly bite off more than you can chew?
Yeah,
you could get involved in so many things that you don't even have time to
monitor the situations at all.
And you don't have time to tell when people are out of their zone or out of the
parameters that they're allowed to work within.
Or you don't have time to help when something goes sideways.
You don't have to.
So,
so you could get there.
And that will happen especially quickly if you have failed to train and mentor
and give directions and give guidance to the leaders that you have that are
actually on the front lines run and things.
So
that's part of it.
Now the other part of it is you can't do any of this if your ego will not allow
you to let things go.
I mean,
you literally said,
I don't want to let go of any projects.
I've said this before.
If you want to be in charge of everything,
you have to be in charge of nothing.
You're goal should be an in charge of nothing.
Only if you're in charge of nothing can you truly be in charge of everything?
Because when you're in charge of every single thing,
guess what?
You can handle nothing.
You're task saturated.
It doesn't work.
So
that's what you need to do.
Get some good solid leaders,
subordinate leaders,
empower them,
train them,
trust them,
make sure they understand where they're going to make sure they understand what
the mission is.
Make sure they understand what the goals are,
make sure they understand what things are outside the box that they need to come
and talk to you about,
and then let them rock and roll.
Boom.